[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages so let's see then what's
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soder and the
chief executive of conservative home
mark wallace both are with us from now
until just before midnight welcome to
both of you
so front pages then we start with the
metro splash nobody told me remarking on
the prime minister's broadcasters
interview with beth rigby and his
attempt to excuse his presence at a
downing street garden party during the
first lockdown of 2020.
the guardian described the interview as
disastrous and reports the mood on the
tory back benches is hardening against
their leader
picturing a crest fallen boris johnson
during that interview the telegraph
reports that he will announce the
scrapping of plan b coveted measures on
wednesday the times also leads on the
rebellion with conservative whips
conceding a no-confidence vote may soon
be triggered
the express goes with the headline what
a sorry state new mps plot to oust the
prime minister
meanwhile the star likens boris johnson
to pinocchio describing the political
situation as a pants on fire crisis
scotland's present journal reports on
the upcoming removal of omicron
restrictions there
the ft leads on microsoft's 75 billion
acquisition of activision blizzard the
gaming company which makes call of duty
and the sun has an exclusive story they
say on strictly come dancing
well just a reminder that by scanning
the qr code that you can see on your
screen right now you can check out the
front pages optimal newspapers while you
watch us and hear from our guests so
let's bring in sonia soda and mark
wallace um good to see both of you in
what we're being told is a really
febrile atmosphere now in westminster
sonja what are you hearing
well these are a terrible set of front
pages to the prime minister aren't they
and um i think the reason why things are
moving so quickly in westminster tonight
is because of a disastrous interview
that boris johnson gave this afternoon
with skye's very own beth rigby
where he was asked about all the
allegations around parties dominic
cummings his former senior adviser uh
said in a blog uh today that uh
boris johnson had been warned uh about
this party that on the uh 20th of may
where he went out and gave a speech to
he'd told parliament he thinks
of me that he didn't realize he thought
it was a work gathering and he went out
gave a speech for 25 minutes and went
back in but in this interview with beth
rigby the line very much was well no one
told me that this party or this
gathering was uh breaking the rules
which has been met with some incredulity
i think in westminster and it really did
have the mark i think of an interview of
the prime minister who's sort of coming
to the end of the road
and i think it was that interview that
has been sort of quite widely mocked um
that has really triggered things moving
quite quickly and there is talk this
evening there are some reports actually
um that that sir graham brady who is the
chairman of the 1922 committee he's the
person who is in receipt of of letters
from backbench mps uh and it takes 54
letters from backbench mps to trigger a
vote of no confidence in the prime
minister there are some reports this
evening
um that i've seen
that he will be making a statement
tomorrow now not quite sure what that
means we don't know if we're at the 54
letters yet but there's a lot of
speculation
uh that mps are plotting particularly in
the 2019 intake and the number of
letters may be approaching that critical
number well let's jump ahead to the
times then in fact uh red wall tory mps
team up to to topple johnson these are
the very people who have been reminded
by some senior tourists that the reason
they've got a job in the houses of
parliament is because of boris johnson
but uh what's the mood amongst that
group then mark
well it's particularly striking i think
that
there is so much frustration among the
2019 intake a number of things to
remember about them firstly there are
over 100 of them you know an eye on a
third of the
parliamentary conservative party was
newly elected in 2019
a higher proportion of that on the back
benches because of course a lot of them
as newer mps aren't ministers they're
not on the payroll votes they're perhaps
more uh free to act in this kind of in
in this way if they so wish the final
thing to remember about them is quite a
lot of them won marginal seats some of
them won by small majorities quite a lot
of them of course that earthquake of the
2019
election uh saw them elected as
conservative councils for the first time
ever in these in in some of these
constituencies so they have all the more
reason
fine to be
grateful to boris johnson for what he
did in that victory but also to be
particularly watchful of their sometimes
slender majorities to be particularly
attentive to
constituents a lot of whom took a chance
for the first time in their lives to
vote conservative and
who are now uh you know
whatever that was going to happen in
this parliament we're going to be
watching closely to see if that um
change of attack was was paying off and
something they wanted to make a lasting
habit or not so
it it's fine to say that actually well
you know boris johnson uh played a
crucial role in a lot of these mps
getting elected
but that doesn't necessarily outweigh
the fact that what they're going to
think about inevitably is also the next
election rather than just the last one
absolutely and the the time suggesting
that this uh group of uh tory mps are
very open about it uh they're calling it
the pork pie plot because one represents
the constituency containing milton
mowbry uh and ross johnson was holding
meetings with groups of the 2019 intake
of mps in parliament uh sonia does that
you know give us to understand that he
would stay and fight should this
threshold of letters
um be passed do you think
oh i think he probably would yeah he i
think so the procedure is um 54 letters
triggers a no-confidence vote i think
boris johnson will fight that because uh
there is a chance that even if the 54
letters are received uh he could still
win a no-confidence fate and it's very
you've got to remember that it's really
hard actually to predict exactly what's
going to happen because so much of this
is happening you know we we're getting
lots of briefing from mps but actually
keeping count of who's in which camp is
quite difficult um particularly because
some mps keep their clothes their cards
very close to their chest in this
situation so um he will but i think
though
you know boris johnson he may be sort of
going around and trying to talk to mps
in parliament now but one of his issues
is he is not really
seen to be a prime minister who works
the tea rooms who um you know really
keeps great relationships uh with back
benches and there's a lot of them as
mark was just saying and i think that's
what's going to come back to bite him
now i think the other thing that's
really important to realize about this
29 intake which are the ins which is a
group of of the parliamentary party who
seems to be most uh moving most quickly
against the prime minister is that if
you look at polling in their seats so
these are the red wall seats the
you know across the the north and the
midlands that
the conservatives won from labour at the
last election
um
at the election and just after the
election boris johnson was outperforming
the conservative party and the
conservative party brand in those seats
now if you look at the polling it's
switched round so boris johnson's
ratings have dropped off a cliff but
he's doing the worst in in the red wall
in those seats so i think this is why as
mark was saying a lot of them are very
very worried looking forwards because um
boris johnson it's true help them win
their majority and win their seats back
in 2019 but in terms of which mps are
most affected by the drop-off in his
ratings if you look at the polling it
really is concentrated in their areas
well mark i know that uh you often do
soundings or pollings uh don't you uh on
your site so my question to you is
what's the mood amongst conservatives do
they want him to go
and if so is there a candidate they
would coalesce around because as we've
heard today many tory mps won't jump
unless they know who they're jumping
towards
indeed so there's a lot of as i
mentioned earlier an awful lot of
frustration quite a lot of
disappointment um we held a snap survey
of our party members uh panel that we
normally take a survey of those each
each month from kind of regular
questions or approval ratings we did a
snap survey friday through saturday
which found for the first time that i i
think i might say 54 of those who
responded thought the prime minister
ought to go now that is a striking
finding and the conservative home uh
members survey i think had boris johnson
winning about 75 percent of the
membership vote in the leadership
election they strongly supported brexit
they gave him sky-high you know over 90
approval ratings in december 2019
january 2020. so there is very deep
frustration and concern i think uh you
know i've when i've been taking
soundings today i've heard of some
places where tory associations are
losing
members uh over in annoyance about this
issue a lot of people who are very
concerned about the potential impact on
the local elections even if they haven't
made their mind up on the prime
minister's future uh yet and frankly
i've spoken to some mps uh being
contacted some mps today who are
very pro the prime minister by general
bent um but who are now feeling
genuinely conflicted doesn't mean
they're necessarily there at this
tipping point yet but they're very
conflicted because they feel a lot of
them like they've given an awful lot of
chances to find an answer a clear answer
to this to turn the ship around to move
the news on
and the story seems to be in charge
rather than the prime minister yeah i
suppose the timing is critical do you
leave boris johnson to take the heat of
the energy price cap story in april the
may elections and then
depose him you know
they're all all of these things are
being thought through i guess aren't
they but quick words sonia if you don't
mind we're running out of time on the
daily telegraph which is plan b to be
scrapped is this is this all part of red
meat or is it is it is it is it part of
the uh the process of wooing some of
those tory mps who never wanted some of
these restrictions in the first place
cabinet meeting we understand on
wednesday to uh to to sign this off
well i think this is the tricky thing
about it for us the voters watching this
play out which is that we want
restrictions to be scrapped when it's
the right time to do it from the
perspective of the science and and the
pandemic and things are looking a lot
better with the omicron wave it has to
be said um but there is a feeling i
think with this prime minister that he's
willing to make announcements uh to his
political benefit
and i think there's no doubt that
they will be hoping in number 10 but an
announcement about lifting the plan b
measures and it's interesting that the
papers are reporting different things so
the guards unit and the times are
reporting that most of the plan b
measures will go but that there will
still be compulsory marks wearing in
shops
and
public transport
for a bit longer whereas the telegraph
is reporting that um they're all going
to go so i think we've got to wait and
see what happens with that but i i think
the the downing street will be this will
take a bit of the pressure off yeah
apologies
we've got lost to pack in second half
too so stay there
we'll look at how the uk government is
preparing for the possibility of russia
invading ukraine that is next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview uh
with us again sonia soda and mark
wallace welcome back to both of you um
so more concern about
russia's intentions in ukraine and
exercise in belarus the u.s secretary of
state flying in for more diplomacy and
the uk uh we're being told in the
telegraph mark is going into crisis mode
tell us more
well we've seen um
uh i'm happy to say in the last couple
of days uh the uk extending further
military aid to help ukraine to
hopefully deter further russian
aggression and and to defend itself if
it does take place what i'm struck by
really is two things firstly that we all
talk about whether russia invades
ukraine the fact is russia has already
invaded ukraine it happened eight years
ago they're still occupying ukrainian
territory and the question is whether
they're going to extend that that
invasion of their neighbor um and
secondly that russia is always out to
try and engineer a win-win
outcome where the west is left feeling
grateful if they somehow manage to give
up some of the things that russia wants
in return for russia not sparking
further land war in europe i think we
need to be very very careful to not end
up um not end up falling into that trap
yeah you make a very good point in fact
our chief correspondents chit ramsey
who's in the donbass region right now
makes the point that they feel like
they've been fighting russia sonia for
the last eight years
yeah mark's absolutely right about that
you know there has been this occupation
of of crimea so um i think this is just
a really really troubling situation on
sort of you know or almost a border with
europe and um you know there were been
reports from the us
at this this last week that the russian
forces may be planning what they call a
false flag operation that's where one
part of russian forces kind of goes
subdiverge and they attack their own
forces and then they use that as an
excuse to launch a military invasion
we've been seeing increasing numbers of
cyber attacks which um you know we most
people are sort of chalking down to
russia so it's a really really troubling
situation and i think the problem is is
what can nato and the west and countries
like the us and the uk do
um and i think they've just got to keep
on kind of um you know making the case
actually i mean the hope
i think russia's actions may end up
backfiring russia once wants to keep
ukraine out of nato's orbit creek uk
ukraine out of nato all together but
actually by taking these actions um you
know i think it's pushing public opinion
even more in the direction of nato
sanjay soda mart wallace thank you both
very much indeed thank you